the economic crisis forced the eu to
bunker down and adopt unpopular measures
to stem the flow of the bleeding economy
but now as europe gets out of the black
is it time for a different approach the
austerity part has done its
let's say due effect on containing the
crisis
now we need to
undertake measures which will give boost
to the economy which will also increase
spending a big crowd for an
inter-parliamentary conference at
parliament bringing together members of
national parliaments meps and
representatives of all institutions the
agenda a simple one finding a way to
wrestle economic governance away from
european powers and create a greater
sense of democracy via wider policy
coordination
diagnostics
instead of talking they did a lot of
arguing there's a much deeper and a much
wider problem and that is the whole
question of the democracy in the
european union and i think that the
people will vote accordingly
unfortunately more from the far right
and it wasn't just members of national
parliaments who clashed even the
president of the european parliament had
a bone to pick europe has been stumbling
from one crisis summit to another
decisions which affect all europeans
we are increasingly being taken by heads
of states and governments behind closed
doors at the height of the crisis the
so-called troika that is the commission
european central bank and international
monetary fund cobbled together to impose
their will on member states with a
crisis over meps are questioning its
legislative legitimacy calling for it to
be dismantled or rebooted the european
parliamentary week continues till
wednesday finding ways to increase the
democratic process of economic policy
correcting macroeconomic imbalances of
member states and financing the real
economy